[MUSIC PLAYING]
REBECCA MOORE: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
My name is Rebecca Moore.
I'm Director of Google Earth.
And I'm very pleased to welcome
my dear friend, Dr. Victoria
Sweet, who just published
a new book called, "Slow
Medicine, the Way to Healing."
I've known Victoria
for several decades,
since nearly the start of
her journey as a physician,
including her 20 years
practicing at Laguna Honda
Hospital in San
Francisco and taking time
to get her PhD in the
history of medicine.
During this period, she's
been on the front lines
of dramatic change
in her profession,
as practicing medicine
has transformed
into delivering health care,
and not always for the better.
Her first book, "God's
Hotel," won widespread awards
and acclaim, leading to
a Guggenheim Fellowship.
And the time-- pay attention to
that word because you will hear
it today a lot--
the time for her to synthesize
and develop her ideas further,
around what she calls slow
medicine and fast medicine
and how these two approaches
are both complementary and
necessary.
Googlers will
particularly appreciate
that Victoria got her
undergraduate degree
in mathematics from Stanford.
Go Stanford.
So please join me in
welcoming Dr. Victoria Sweet.
[APPLAUSE]
VICTORIA SWEET: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Rebecca,
for that introduction.
Thank you all for
being here today.
And thanks to Google for
doing something this--
really unusual for a
big for-profit company
to be willing to sponsor
books and speeches by authors.
It's a really wonderful
thing, and special I think.
It tells a lot about Google.
I would like to
add that not only
did I get my mathematics degree
at Stanford, it was my major.
But my minor was classics.
And that is a stream, as two
things have woven their way
through my life.
So what I would like
to do this afternoon--
I'll speak for about 40 minutes.
And I'll be explaining kind of
how I actually got right here.
That's the first
part of the talk.
And the second
part of the talk, I
want to talk about
what's gone on
with medicine during my
career and what I think
we can do to make it better.
So I'm going to start with my--
yes.
So the first thing you
should know about me
is that I don't consider
myself a natural-born doctor.
And by that I mean Growing up
I never watched doctor shows
or went to volunteer
in a hospital.
And if somebody was sick, I
didn't want to hear about it
or have anything to do with it.
And, in fact, the
first time I had
to draw blood in medical
school, I passed out.
So definitely not a
natural-born doctor.
What happened was at
the end of college,
I was looking for a way
to synthesize these two
parts of myself, the
mathematics, the classics,
the history, the humanities,
and the sciences.
And I ran into the writings of
Carl Jung, the psychiatrist.
He'd written a memoir
called "Memories, Dreams
and Reflections."
And I ran into it by
accident in the library.
And I found myself enthralled.
I was enthralled, first
of all, by the meaning
he expected from his own life
and also by the kind of life
he set up for himself.
This is a stone house he had
built himself on Lake Zurich.
And this is where he saw
patients in the morning,
neurotic, well-paying
and illuminated manuscripts
and studied alchemy
in the afternoon.
I thought this was a great life.
And that's what I wanted
to do when I grew up.
And that's how I got
to medical school
because I was going to
be a union psychiatrist.
Then it turned out I
liked medical school
a lot more than I thought I
would, especially the last two
years of medical school,
when you finally get
a chance to see real patients.
I loved what's
called the work-up.
I loved the history,
taking the history,
trying to figure out the
patient's story because there
was so much psychology to it.
Hearing what the patient said
and didn't say, seeing what--
the way he said or she said,
the answer to the question.
And then I was
examining the patient.
And it turns out I actually
liked touching people.
I particularly liked
the physical exam
because there was
so much I could
learn from that about what the
patient had and didn't have.
And then there was
putting it all together
in a diagnosis, and the
treatment, and the plan.
It was a logical,
brilliant method.
Nevertheless, I
continued my first idea.
And I went into a
psychiatric residency.
And I was a little bit naive.
So my psychiatric
residency took place
in the only locked psychiatric
ward in our county.
So consequently, the
patients were not
Jung's well-paying, neurotic,
articulate patients.
They were severely psychotic.
And they responded a lot
more to the, um, medicines
we used than they did to
the talk therapy I tried.
So after I got my license, after
that first year of internship,
I just went out and practiced
medicine for several years
in various clinics.
And it was fascinating.
Because the county clinics
and the community clinics
would get waves of
immigrants every time
there was a war
or a rumor of war.
And they would bring with
them their diseases and also
their different way of
looking at the body.
I saw everything
in those clinics.
I saw three cases of leprosy.
And this is right around
here, when I did this.
I saw most every
parasite there was
and saw many unusual diseases.
And I was also interested
in these different ways
of looking at the body.
And so after a while, I
decided that I might as well
admit that I liked medicine.
I went back and did three years
of a regular medical residency.
And then I went back to
the community clinics.
And the longer I practiced
medicine, the more impressed
I was by the logical
method of writing out
a diagnosis and a treatment.
But I was also more
and more impressed
by what this medicine, modern
medicine, left out, which was,
of course, anything
that wasn't logical.
So after a while, I started
reading alternative medicines,
naturopathy, homeopathy,
Chinese medicine,
and Ayurvedic medicine.
And for a while, I even
thought about learning Chinese,
so I could understand
Chinese medicine
from the inside;
or Sanskrit, so I
could understand Indian
medicine from the inside.
But eventually, I
decided that even
if I did get to that point,
that I could understand them,
their cultures were still
too different from my own
to understand their different
ways of looking at the body.
It was this rather
discouraging moment
that I discovered the writings
of a very unusual 12th century
woman.
Her name was Hildegard of
Bingen. And she was a mystic.
She was a composer.
She was an artist.
She was a theologian.
But she also, as it turned out,
was a medical practitioner.
And she'd written a
book on her medicine.
And as I stood there and read
her book, in the library again,
I was impressed by the medicine
that she was recounting.
Because it wasn't the medieval
medicine I'd expected,
the tongue of newt,
eye of frog medicine I
expected from a
medieval medical text.
It was real medicine,
for real patients,
with real diseases
I could recognize.
But it was based on a completely
different model of the body
from our modern medical model.
I couldn't quite put my finger
on how it was different.
But I decided then
and there that I
was going to go back
to school and get
a PhD in medical history,
with Hildegard as my focus.
But I didn't want to
stop practicing medicine.
I wanted to do this half-time.
And I spent a couple of
months looking around
for a half-time
position, which was
rather difficult at the time.
Until finally I discovered--
I was offered a position
at a very unusual hospital
in San Francisco, which
was called Laguna Honda
Hospital, in San Francisco.
And when I drove over
for the first time
and saw it high on that
hill, I was taken aback.
This was about 20 years ago now.
It looked like a
medieval monastery.
It had red-tiled roofs,
and cream-colored walls,
and a turret, and a bell tower,
where patients, it turned out,
used to go up and smoke.
And I went on my interview.
And the medical
director took me around.
I had never seen a
hospital like this.
It was on 62 acres of land in
the middle of San Francisco.
It had 1,200 patients.
It had enormous grounds.
The patients all
got taken care of on
these old-fashioned
wards, those open wards
you see in the old
movies from the 1930s.
It had an X-ray
department where we
could take our own
X-rays and a lab
with a microscope where we
could look at our own slides.
It had a chapel, a
little small chapel,
that was run by the county.
It had a chapel that actually
looked more like a church,
with stained glass windows,
and polished wooden pews,
and very politically incorrect
stations of the cross
along the walls.
And then we went out.
And the medical director
showed me the grounds,
which were enormous.
There was an aviary,
so that patients could
watch chickens hatch from eggs.
There was a green house, so
that patients could pop plants.
And there was even a
barnyard, so the patients
could see animals, even
if they were bed-bound.
Then we walked
back to her office
and she offered me the job.
Well, I didn't know.
I wasn't sure.
I had never seen a place
like that before in my life.
But it was only place that
would let me practice medicine
part-time.
So I said I would
stay for two months.
And I ended up
staying for 20 years.
Because it turned out to be a
fascinating place to practice.
And that was for
one specific reason.
It had originally been called
the San Francisco Almshouse.
This was the first rendition
of Laguna Honda in the 1860s.
And the almshouse
was actually how
we used to take care
of the sick poor
before there was
health insurance.
We had a way of taking
care of the sick poor.
And that was this system
that was the big, old county
hospital, where anybody could
show up and get taken care of.
And then if they needed
more care than that,
we had someplace to send them.
So this is where,
in the old days,
we could send people
who were mentally ill,
who needed more care, who
were unemployed, who'd
just been let out of prison.
We actually had a system.
And Laguna Honda was the
San Francisco Almshouse.
And it's how I got the title for
my last book because this is--
the system that we have
came from France, and Europe
in general.
And in French, the word for
almshouse is hotel-dieu.
It's God's hotel.
So that's how I got the name.
And the reason I ended
up staying so long
is because typically
the almshouse
would get the bottom
1/10 of 1% of patients.
So my patients were all
three standard deviations
from the mean, any mean.
They were the tallest and
they were the shortest.
They were the fattest and
they were the thinnest.
They were the oldest, and
the youngest, and the nicest,
and the meanest of any
patients I ever had.
And, because the
whole catchment area
was San Francisco at the
time, with 600,000 people,
if a disease would occur in
one in a hundred thousand,
I'd see a couple.
So it was a fascinating
place medically.
I just went through
the rare diseases
in Harrison's
textbook of medicine
and checked them off
as they would come up.
So it was a fascinating
place to practice.
And I ended up
staying for 20 years.
But it also a wonderful place
to practice because health care
efficiency had not yet arrived.
We were over the hill to
the poorhouse literally.
And people kind
of left us alone.
I mean, we had
standards and things.
People paid attention
to what we did.
But mostly, I had something
that doctors today mostly
don't have.
And that is the time to
take care of my patients,
to properly examine
them, to figure out
what was actually
wrong with them,
to get the right diagnosis
and the right treatment.
And the longer I was
there, the more impressed I
was by not only how, um--
how satisfying that
was for me as a doc,
but how efficient it was, even
from a health care efficiency
point of view.
And I'll give you an example.
The typical patient
at Laguna Honda
would arrive on between 15 and
26 medications, of which they
only needed about four or five.
But no other doctor had had the
time to go through the chart,
go through the patient, figure
out whether they actually
needed that medicine,
maybe even try
taking them off that
medication to see how they did.
I found that most
of the patients
could be handled very
well on five medications.
So I was taking them off between
10 and 15 medications, which,
if you figure it
out economically,
is incredibly cost effective
for the extra few hours of time
it took me.
So I was quite happy there.
And then meanwhile-- of course,
I'd gone back to study--
so this is actually what I call
the efficiency of inefficiency.
Meanwhile, I'd gone back,
as I had decided to do,
to get my PhD in medical
history with Hildegard of Bingen
as my focus.
And what I decided to
do was to really learn
Hildegard's medicine as
if I were its student,
by reading her medical text
in its original language
and by understanding what
people were doing around her.
So I took classes and
learned Latin because she
wrote in Latin.
And I learned medieval Latin
because she wrote actually
in medieval Latin.
I learned medieval
German and German
because that's what the
secondary literature was in.
And learned paleography
and codicology,
so I could actually read
the handwritten texts
which they had back then.
And I also experimented.
Because I figured if I'd been
her student in the Middle Ages,
I'd sort of have a sense of
using her different recipes
and prescriptions.
So I planted a
medieval herb garden.
And I brewed up some of
her potions and syrups.
I tried her medicinal beers.
And I baked some of her
anti-depressant cookies.
And what I found over
time, I got more and more
interested in the difference
between Hildegard's model
of the body and our
model of the body
because they were
clearly very different.
Our model of the body is
fundamentally based on the idea
that the body is a machine
and the doctor is a mechanic,
looking for what's broken
and trying to fix it, repair
it, or replace it.
Hildegard's model
was very different,
I gradually learned
over the years.
Hildegard's model was much
more of the body as a plant,
rather than as a machine,
and the doctor more
like a gardener,
than a mechanic.
What's the difference?
The difference is that someone
has to fix a broken machine.
But a plant can heal itself.
And Hildegard had a name
for the power of a plant
to heal itself.
She called it "viriditas,"
from the Latin "viridis,"
that means green.
So it was the greening
power of a plant
to grow, to produce seeds,
and to repair itself up when
it was injured.
And she believed that human
beings also have this power.
And that the job
of the doctor was
more to remove what was in the
way of the patient's viriditas
and to support it
with the basics,
than to do something
to the patient.
So this was a very
interesting model.
And it took me
years to understand
how to apply it to the
patients I had at Laguna Honda.
But gradually, I began to
see that not only could I
help a patient by figuring out
what diagnosis they actually
had, but once I
had the diagnosis,
to step back and see what
was in the way of viriditas
and what could I
do to support it.
The longer I practiced
medicine at Laguna Honda,
the more I realized that
this was a very helpful way
of looking at patients.
And I began to think of it
as sort of the slow medicine,
as opposed to the fast
medicine I also used,
which was so effective for
what I consider fast diseases.
So, for instance, if
you come to the hospital
because you have appendicitis
and you need an appendectomy,
or you come to the hospital, and
you are having a heart attack
and you need an angioplasty,
or even if you have cancer,
this is when, what I would
call by contrast, fast medicine
or modern medicine, based on the
model of the body as a machine,
works great.
But after your appendectomy,
and after your angioplasty,
and after your
chemotherapy, this
is when modern medicine, with
this idea of coming in, fixing
what's broken, falls down.
And what I learned
at Laguna Honda is,
when I used both models
together, first fast and then
slow medicine, the
patients did the best.
They did remarkably well.
Many of them were
actually able to go home,
sort of unexpectedly.
And during the 20 years
I practiced medicine,
while I was practicing
medicine at Laguna Honda,
we eventually got discovered
and our halcyon days
of having enough time
began to disappear.
And, first by health
care efficiency experts,
who showed up one day,
walking through the place
and horrified to discover the
aviary, and the greenhouse,
and particularly the open wards.
And the Department
of Justice finally,
eventually, showed up
and told Laguna Honda
that they were going to have to
tear the place down and rebuild
a new health care facility,
that had private rooms for all
of the patients,
rather than keep
the patients on the open wards.
And at that point, I decided
to take some time off and write
a book about what
I'd seen there.
That was my first book.
And also to think about
what I had seen so far
in my life as a physician.
It seemed to me,
when I thought about,
that in my life as a physician,
the pendulum of health care
had swung from the
personal to the efficient.
And I have been more and
more impressed by what
that leaves out.
So, for instance, the results
of the kind of health care
efficiency we've had over the
last 20 years, as you can see,
is that health care
costs have kept
rising no matter what
health care economists have
tried to do.
They've tried to do
all kinds of schemes
for getting a hold
of health care.
And this is not true just
in the United States,
but across the world.
Health care costs keep
rising every year,
despite DRGs and HMOs, and
managed health care systems,
everything we've tried.
Trying to understand
what was going
on in the system as a whole, I
decided to look at Laguna Honda
specifically and
ask myself, what
had gone on there in
the last 20 years?
So I figured out that
in the last 20 years,
as a cost-cutting measure,
the patients we had,
had gone from about
1,178 down to 780.
This was as a
cost-cutting measure.
So we were taking care
of a lot fewer patients.
Of course,
correspondingly, the number
of doctors we had went down,
was cut, from 32, to nine.
And, correspondingly
also, the clinical staff,
that's the nurses,
and the therapists,
and the social workers, was also
cut as a cost-cutting measure,
from about 15,000, to 1,200.
And yet, at Laguna Honda, every
year the budget has increased.
So I asked myself, well,
what counted for that?
And I realized that even
though the patients were fewer,
and the doctors were
considerably fewer,
and the clinical
staff had been cut,
the total staff was
actually the same.
There were more and more
administrators every year.
What did all those
administrators
do, I asked myself?
Well, what I realized was
that, when I thought about it,
that the one thing we
had more of at Laguna
Honda at the end of my time
there, than at the beginning
of the time, were forms.
So when I first got there,
we had paper charts.
And we had two single-page
forms in the chart.
And the day before
I left Laguna Honda,
I pulled out one of the
paper charts just randomly.
And I started
looking through it.
And I counted how
many forms that were.
There were 43 forms
in that chart.
And none of them were
single-page forms.
They were 10 page, 20 page.
There were so many
forms that the charts
would explode from the forms.
And medical records
had to show up and thin
out the doctors' notes.
And this, to sort
of clarify things,
because I do have somewhat
of a mathematical mind,
I created this chart at the time
when I was figuring this out.
OK, now this is working.
So this is a chart I created
at the time on a napkin,
as Becca pointed
out the other day.
So these are the
patients, going down.
I was trying to
understand this system.
There are the
doctors, going down.
There's the budget going up, the
clinical staff, the total staff
staying about the same.
And this is the number of forms.
And what I realized is, is that
if current trends continued,
by 2024 there would be no
patients at Laguna Honda.
There would be two doctors.
There would be a staff of
1,400, a budget of $275 million,
and an infinite number of forms.
And I began to think of this
as doing less with more.
And the thing that's interesting
about it is-- and crucial
about it-- is exactly
the same as the thing
that's been happening in
the country as a whole.
Let me show you what I mean.
So this is the
country as a whole.
So if you look at the
growth of its physicians
and administrators,
here's what you find.
So I'll interpret this
a little bit for you.
These are the number of
docs, percentage growth.
So it's about doubled.
So the docs have about doubled,
in tandem with the population
has about doubled.
So there's about the same
number of docs per patient,
and vice versa, as
there always have been.
The yellow is a number
of administrators.
There are 35 times as
many administrators
as there used to be.
And as you can see,
just like Laguna Honda,
the budget has continued
to go up every year.
And what do all those docs do?
What do all these
administrators do, I should say?
Well, this just is interesting.
This is HHS paperwork.
Really, they should
say electronic computer
work, in millions of
hours, millions of hours.
Just in the last 10
years, it has doubled.
From 350 million
hours, it has doubled
to almost 700 million hours.
Why?
Well, what's happened is,
is that because of all
this paperwork that the
administrators have generated
for various reasons,
we've ended up
in a situation where your
doctor doesn't have enough time
to look at patients anymore.
This is a sentence I've
heard over and over again
over the last five years as
I've gone around and spoken
about the book.
And I put it--
I don't know if you can see
when you're sitting here.
But this was a rather
scandalous drawing
that appeared in the "Journal
of the American Medical
Association" a few years ago.
A doc had it published.
It was a mother who
brought it to him.
It was a drawing by her
five-year-old daughter,
about my visit to the doctor.
And you can't see it too well.
But this is the daughter
sitting on the exam table.
Behind it is the mom, holding
a little baby, and a friend,
I believe.
And this is the doctor, who
is looking at the computer.
This is where we're
spending our time.
And from experience, in
general, and experience,
particularly at Laguna
Honda, I believe
in or to have a good
health care system,
we actually need to
put inefficiency,
that is unregulated free time
for the doctors and the nurses
to have the time to
look at their patients
and to get off the computer.
And the question then becomes,
how can we get that time back?
Because, as you've just seen,
we have actually the same number
of doctors and patients
as we've always had.
But the doctors are
spending a bunch of time,
not with the patients.
So that the patient doesn't
feel looked at anymore
and isn't looked at anymore.
So when I was thinking about
this, trying a figure out, OK,
so how could we get the time
back, I asked myself, well,
what do we spend our time on?
And, in a way, time is the
viriditas of health care.
So I can do a
viriditas analysis,
and ask myself, well, what is
in the way of doctors having
enough time with patients?
What do doctors
spend their time on?
So I came up with three
fundamental things
doctors spend their time
on, forms; what I call fast
administration, as opposed
to slow administration;
and lousy electronic
health records.
By forms, I mean this
whole contraption
that has come upon us with
electronic health records
and administration, screens,
logins, alerts, e-mails,
script, that are based
on this whole idea
that if it's not documented,
it didn't happen.
And if it is documented,
it did happen.
And we can talk
about that a bit.
And second, what I'm thinking of
as fast administration, which I
consider a problem with style.
This idea by administrators,
that if they come up
with a form, they're done.
If they come up with a paradigm,
a script for us to follow,
the problem was solved.
And last, and really
mainly, the easiest thing
to fix, to get doctors back
their time, electronic health
records, that take all our time.
And this is what I'd like
to sort of zero in now
on for little bit, about the
problem with electronic health
records and how I think we
can actually get doctors
back some of our
time with patients,
some of our free time, some
of our inefficient time.
So we can sit down with
patients, look at them,
and actually examine them.
So what's happened in
the past about 10 years
is electronic health records.
We used to use the paper charts.
The biggest flaw
with paper charts
was that, if you went
to the emergency room
and nothing happened, and then
you came back to your doctor,
they couldn't tell you what--
nobody knew what was going on.
We had to get them to
send us, to Xerox things,
and send the paper.
So more than about 10
years ago, what they did
is that if we had electronic
health records on the computer,
and you went to the emergency
room and had something done,
it would magically appear
in your doctor's office,
on the doctor's computer.
And so that's kind
of was the way
that electronic health
records were envisioned.
But that's not what happened.
Because there's so
much money in health
care these days, and so much
money in electronic health
records, at this point,
the last time I checked,
there were 1,100 for-profit
electronic health record
companies.
And they're engineered to that
they don't talk to each other.
So it's actually even
worse than it used to be.
So how bad is it?
Well, doctors have ended up--
so first of all, the
electronic health records
haven't done what
they should have done.
But, in addition,
they've been used
to acquire big data for the
pharmaceuticals, marketing,
and advertising.
And the doctor has been
right in the middle of that.
The doctor has been plumped in
front of the electronic health
records, which are
based on a model of--
based on an old billing model,
that comes back from the 1970s
and is incredibly clumsy.
So clumsy that in
a Stanford study,
doctors were
actually spending 70%
of their time on the computer.
But in a more sort
of shocking study,
Kaiser got tired of hearing
how whiny their doctors were
about how much time they
spent on the computer.
So they actually decided
to see how much time
do our doctors spend
on the computer.
And they picked two hospitals.
And they spent two months
actually keeping track
of all the stroke doctor--
all the keystrokes.
And then they added
all that time up
and they divided by
the number of doctors.
This was in two separate
hospitals over two months.
And they discovered
that the doctors,
out of an eight-hour
day, were spending
10 hours on the computer.
So this is where
our time is going.
And we could get it back
if we had electronic health
records that only
took as much time
as the paper records,
which would take about 15%
of their time.
So in a 15-minute visit, they'd
take 2 and 1/2 minutes of time,
rather than taking more than 15
minutes of that 15-minute time.
We can get the doctors
off the computer,
back to doing the
kind of care that I
was able to give at Laguna
Honda, where we can actually
get the right diagnosis
and the right treatment.
So that's actually what
I'm focusing on now
and one of the reasons
I wanted to speak up
to this particular audience.
Because I think
it's very possible
to create an electronic
health record that's simple,
that's cheap, that takes,
like, 2 and 1/2 minutes instead
of 15 minutes, and that
everybody could use
and would want to use.
So some of my rather larger
ideas for getting control
would be to have the
opposite of the three things
I had before about what
we spend our time on.
So we could start
in terms of forms,
with a law for the
conservation of forms.
So my experience is that we
have enough forms already
and that we don't
need any new forms.
And I think in most
hospital situations,
that when an administrator
comes up with a new form,
they should find at least
one form of equal length
to get rid of.
Second of all, slow
administration.
I think that if administrators
would think and would
realize that every time
they send an email,
organize a meeting, or
come up with a new form,
they are directly taking
time away from the doc.
And last, we need the
electronic health record
that preserves story.
Because the problem with
electronic health records
based on the billing platform--
I don't know if anybody
here has ever seen them.
But they make it
literally impossible
to understand what's actually
gone on with your patient.
And the last thing
that I think we
need to do in our
health care system
is to also start some
experiments with being slow.
And some of the ideas
I've come up with for that
is to just, in the
hospital situation,
to have a slow
medicine clinic, where
the doctor would
get as much time
as they needed with patients.
It's a novel idea.
Slow medicine beds,
so that we had
a few beds in the hospital where
patients could be admitted when
they needed a work-up,
instead of getting piecemeal,
being sent all over
town when they get sick.
And finally, a slow
medicine consult service.
That would be the equivalent
of an oncology consult service
or a cardiology consult service.
But it would be for slow
medicine, for the patients
that we end up as doctors
getting in the hospital, that
are so sick and complicated.
And we know we cannot figure
out what's going on with them
and we have to discharge them.
Instead, we call it the slow
medicine consult service.
And have them arrive, and
figure the patient out.
Because in the end, I'm
not a complete pessimist
about health care.
I'm a pessimist and an optimist.
I think that health care is--
with health care, the glass
is half full and half empty,
in this way.
That, in a lot of ways,
we've done a fantastic job
with fast medicine.
That this model of
the body as a machine
and the doctors as a mechanic
has been incredibly powerful.
If you look at what's happened
over the last 150 years
in medical history,
nobody would ever
want to go back to
practicing medicine
the way we did even
20 or 30 years ago.
But on our way to fast
medicine, this idea
that doctors would
have enough time
to get the right diagnosis,
to examine the patient,
to get the right treatment
has sort of disappeared.
And I think we need to go back
and reinstitute this second way
of looking at a patient.
For more on my book, which
some of you have, and last,
I always like to remember who,
in the end, won that race.
So thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
We'll have some
questions and answers.
REBECCA MOORE: Thank you.
We do have a Q&A. I do have
a question to start with.
But people, please think
of questions for Dr. Sweet.
So you're here at Google.
And a big focus for us now
is machine learning and AI,
which is being applied to
all facets of human endeavor
and actually creating
a lot of breakthroughs.
Do you have any thoughts on how
machine learning and AI could,
in fact, play a role
in solving this problem
with electronic medical
health records, that
lose the story, doctors spending
too much time as data entry
clerks?
Your thoughts on that.
VICTORIA SWEET: Yeah, I do.
So that's really the
issue of the hour.
There's 1,100 different
electronic health records
systems.
But they all look
exactly the same.
They're all
fundamentally the same.
And they all lose the story.
They're little bits
of information.
They're boxes, that the
docs have filled out.
The old paper charts
were basically books.
They were basically books.
And they preserved the
story of the patient.
They were books
because they had pages.
And they went through time.
They had a beginning,
and a middle, and an end.
And this was incredibly useful
as a doc because you could
go through and you could read
about how the patient first
came in, and the
things that were done,
and what the nurse thought,
and what the social worker did,
what meds they were
on, and what labs.
It was very useful
for serving the story.
And then what happened when
electronic health records came
in, because they were built
on this piddling platform,
electronic health
records that we
look at today, what the
doctors are all looking at,
is a screen.
And it's a screen with boxes,
and alerts, and logins.
So the doc is sitting
there, logging things in.
Pharmacy has got a
whole different section.
Nursing has a different section.
And these are all little boxes.
And you cannot figure out from
the electronic health records
what's gone wrong
with the person.
I know this because
my own father got sick
a couple of years
ago and was admitted
to a hospital with
the wrong diagnosis.
And this particular
hospital, at the time,
the doctors and
nurses were actually
reading "God's Hotel"
in their book club.
So I was a bit of a VIP.
Nevertheless, I could
not get those docs
to change his diagnosis.
They thought he'd had a stroke.
But he hadn't had a stroke.
He'd had a seizure.
And he had a
history of seizures.
We all knew he had seizures.
I couldn't get them to focus.
They even tried to
change the diagnosis
in the electronic health record.
But they couldn't change it.
So every time a new shift of
doctors and nurses came down,
they continued to treat
my dad with the treatment
for a stroke.
And eventually, he was on so
much medicine, the medicine
for the stroke,
and then medicine
for the side effects of the
medicine for the stroke,
and the medicine for
the blood pressure, kind
of this sort of thing,
that he was clearly
going to die in the hospital.
So I was rather
worried about him.
And I realized the only way
I could really get him out
of the hospital was to convince
the doctors that we thought--
we had decided he was a
hospice-level patient.
And we were wanting
to just let him die.
So once they accepted that,
they let us take him home.
And I took him off all the
medicines that he was on.
And he had his 95th birthday
about two months ago
and cut his own cake
with a very large knife.
I mean, he did it on purpose.
So I thought perhaps I'd
missed something because I
couldn't-- there was no
chart for me to look at.
And I was worried, well,
maybe he did have a stroke.
I mean, maybe I'm wrong.
So I asked for those
electronic health
records, his electronic
records, from 10 days.
And I got them.
And it was amazing.
It took me four hours to
go through those electronic
records of my dad's.
There were 810 pages.
I had two questions I
was trying to answer.
What medications was he
on at any particular time?
And why had they made
that diagnosis of stroke?
And I could not figure it out.
I couldn't figure out anything.
It was just page after page of--
it was just-- there was no way.
And I spent four hours.
And I knew what I
was looking for.
So nobody who came
to see him, when
they looked at those
electronic records,
could possibly have figured
out what was wrong with him.
So when you compare these
beautiful old-fashioned paper
charts, it would have been easy.
I would have just gone
through and looked
at his original
diagnosis, how he got it.
I would have turned back and
looked at the labs, which
would have been in a section.
I would have looked
at the X-rays.
I could have seen
the nurses' notes.
I could have followed
the doctors' narrative.
I could have followed the story.
It would have been a snap.
So my idea is that
we take this model,
this old-fashioned model,
that's made out of paper,
and we just turn
it into electrons.
So we have an electronic paper
chart that preserves the story.
And how would we do that?
So my imagination is that we
already had this technology.
It's called an e-book.
So why not just use
this idea of an e-book
for our electronic
health records?
So if you, for instance,
came into my office,
you were a new patient,
we have some HIPAA
privacy-protected cloud, that
I can take a new chart out of.
That's your chart.
And it looks like a book.
It's on the computer.
But it looks like a book.
And I should be able to, I
think, I should be able to--
if I like to write, how come I
can't, like, handwrite a note?
Or if I like to
dictate, why can't I?
If I like to type, I
should be able to do that.
If I want to write in French,
I should be able to do that.
I should be able to write
the narrative of what happens
and my physical exam.
I should be able to turn
that chart around, go
look at-- fluff
through the chart.
Why can't we do that?
And then that would mean
that if we did it this way,
then when I'm done
with your chart,
I put it back in the cloud.
Let's suppose you have to
go to the emergency room.
They can just go take that
chart out of the cloud
and write in it themselves.
I don't see why
you can't do that.
And so then the problem
becomes, well, what do we do--
because one of the reasons
electronic health records
are being used this
way is for billing.
And the second reason
is because of big data.
Oh, big data is very valuable.
This idea that you can
figure out instantly
how many patients
have hypertension,
or how many patients--
this kind of information
is very valuable.
Just financially,
it's very valuable.
It's valuable to marketing.
It's valuable to
pharmaceuticals.
It's valuable to the health
care industry as a whole.
But right now what
we have, is we
have the docs
acting fundamentally
as data care providers.
That's what we do.
We--
REBECCA MOORE: Data
care providers--
VICTORIA SWEET: Data care--
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
That's a new one.
VICTORIA SWEET: We
put-- that's our job.
We spend 110% of our time in
front of your electronic health
records, simply
entering data, so
that big data can be produced.
So that big data can be sold
and used by these companies.
And so what I don't--
it seems to me--
Becca and I have actually
talked about this--
is, if artificial
intelligence can
do all these marvelous
things, why can't they
take my handwritten
notes and all this stuff
and just stick
artificial intelligence
between the necessary big data
and my electronic paper chart,
and if artificial
intelligence turned my chart
into all the big data you want?
Why do I have to do it?
REBECCA MOORE: It works for me.
So that is your challenge.
VICTORIA SWEET: Yes.
I challenge Google.
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
The gauntlet is now thrown.
VICTORIA SWEET: Yes.
I think we should do that.
Because if we could do that,
it would be phenomenal.
We could have doctors who could
spend 2 and 1/2 minutes-- we'd
have our 12 and 1/2 minutes back
with patients, to examine them.
The big data people,
who like all that stuff,
they'd still be happy.
And you guys could do
something fantastic.
And I think it would
be very interesting
for artificial intelligence
to look at that as a problem.
REBECCA MOORE: So I
have one more question.
But then I want to let
other people do it too.
So in the news this week--
I think it was just like
yesterday or the day before--
it was suddenly announced
that some of the health policy
setters have changed the
standard for hypertension.
And they've lowered the
level of your blood pressure
at which they consider
that you have a problem
and should go on medication.
And I think I saw
yesterday, that now
50% of the adult population is
now considered hypertensive.
And, in fact-- then I
heard on NPR last night,
something about someone, who is
sort of an apologist for this,
was saying, but it's OK.
We've determined that it's
safe to medicate people
at these lower levels
of blood pressure.
So it's fine.
I found that alarming.
And I just wondered if you
had any thoughts on this.
VICTORIA SWEET: Yes.
Well, I do have clients.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, so my first
thought actually was--
so they've been doing this
for decades and decades.
So long ago, when I
was in medical school,
and they had actually--
so the way that docs determine
what's high and what's low is--
we don't really know actually.
It's mostly statistical.
We basically decide
one standard deviation
from the mean, or two standard
deviations from the mean,
by definition.
That's what we do.
Because we don't--
A priori, we wouldn't know
what a normal sodium is.
The way we even know
a normal sodium is we
do billions of
sodiums in people.
And then we declare these to
be normal, within, let's say,
one standard deviation.
And everything else
to be abnormal.
And then, sometimes, we'll
be able to connect up
a disease state or a symptom
with those abnormalities.
So with hypertension, that
was done in around the '60s
and '70s.
And the original definition
of hypertension was actually--
I may be one of
the only people who
remember this-- was actually
about a 180 over 110.
That was two standard
deviations from the mean.
And that was correlated with
significant kidney problems,
when you have that high
a blood pressure, heart
problems, and extra strokes.
So that actually was
actually shown as evidence.
Then, over the years--
but that's two
standard deviations.
What do you get,
7% of the people
are taking their medications.
That's not very much.
That's not very good.
So about, um, about 20
years ago, they lowered--
they just randomly
lowered, and said,
from now on it's going to
be one standard deviation
from the mean, which
is 160 over 90,
which nobody has ever
correlated with actual damage.
But they just assume, if really
high blood pressure was bad,
then kind of-- this
was still high.
It was one standard
deviation from the mean.
So then we had in an epidemic
of high blood pressure
because suddenly we had
15% of the people had--
statistically-- you guys
are all mathematicians.
Once you go from two
standard deviations
to one standard
deviation, you have 15%.
So, my god, we
have this epidemic.
Because it used to be 7%
of people had hypertension.
Now, 15% have hypertension.
But then, we have 15% more
people taking medications,
which is very useful.
So then about--
REBECCA MOORE: I think
you're being sarcastic.
VICTORIA SWEET: --15 years ago,
we declared that 140 over 90
was hypertension.
So then we had
about 20% of people
who were now hypertensive,
about 20% of people.
And then the
cardiologists got together
and decided that any amount of
blood pressure was bad for you.
They did.
Remember?
They did do that.
But they didn't really
officially declare it
until this last week,
where they've lowered it
once again, down to 130,
which falls actually
way within the mean, the
mean of a blood pressure.
So consequently, 50%
of-- it's not surprising
that 50% of people
now have hypertension
with the definition.
How would they not,
just statistically?
And that means 50% of people
are going to be on medications.
REBECCA MOORE: Do these
medications have side effects?
VICTORIA SWEET: Yes.
They all have side effects.
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
Anyway, I'm asking
too many questions.
Anyone else have a
question for Dr. Sweet?
VICTORIA SWEET: Or a comment?
REBECCA MOORE: Or a comment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] All right.
I have a microphone.
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
Great.
AUDIENCE: He's up front.
VICTORIA SWEET: Yeah.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Actually, you--
AUDIENCE: Comment on that.
AUDIENCE: How much is that
mean shifting over time though,
since the '60s?
VICTORIA SWEET:
What do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Well, you said it's
so many standard deviations
from the mean.
VICTORIA SWEET: That's right.
AUDIENCE: And now, are--
VICTORIA SWEET: So
the mean stays--
AUDIENCE: Is that mean
shifting itself over time?
VICTORIA SWEET: No.
So the mean-- All right.
I see what you're saying.
That's a really
interesting question.
That's actually a
very good question.
As far as I know, the mean
is still the average-ish.
It's still about 120 over
70, as far as I know.
I mean, that's actually a
real interesting question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I don't know if anybody does.
Do you know,
[? Jumi, ?] offhand?
I think it's still 120 over 70.
It's just, they
keep coming down,
just like they've
done with statins.
It's exactly the same model.
I mean statins, your
elevated cholesterol
was two standard
deviations from the mean,
which was going to be an LDL, a
bad cholesterol of, like, 180.
And then they went to 160.
And then they went
to 130, which,
again, meant that 50% of
the people, not surprising,
were hypercholesterolemic,
because that was, like,
within 50% of the
people had a LDL of 130.
And then the cardiologist
declared that it doesn't really
matter and we should have as
low cholesterol as possible,
even though the white
matter of your brain
is white because it's
made out of cholesterol.
[LAUGHTER]
Ah.
And [? Jumi ?] puts in,
and your sex hormones
are made out of cholesterol.
And vitamin D is actually
1-dehydroxy cholesterol.
So, yes.
REBECCA MOORE: All right.
VICTORIA SWEET: Salim?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
VICTORIA SWEET: Did I get
your name right, Salim?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VICTORIA SWEET: Salim.
Yes.
Correct.
Good.
AUDIENCE: So I will
ave my question
about forms and administrators
for later maybe.
But I'm more curious--
or maybe I'll start
with the preface
that we're a part of
a technology company.
And it certainly
feels like the world
is moving faster and faster.
And we want to, whether it's
multitasking or enabling
people to move faster,
you put a lot of the onus
on the medical
system and doctors
to slow the system
down, it seems like,
to not treat the
body like a machine.
Yet, what are your thoughts
from a patient's perspective?
The ability to take
some ibuprofens
when I have a headache
and solve the problem is--
that's nice to hand that
off to the doctor and say,
why are you prescribing
me ibuprofens?
But I can get this
off the shelf.
How do patients approach
medicine differently
and slow things down, and
look for longer solutions,
moralistic solutions?
VICTORIA SWEET: That's a
really thoughtful question.
Thank you.
Well, what I would say is this.
I think there's actually
two flavors of patients,
two flavors of people really.
Some people really
like medications.
They like meds.
They like labs.
They like going to the doctor.
They like-- they just like it.
They like meds.
And then there's a
whole other group
that don't like meds, of which
I happen to belong to them.
And what usually happens
with docs in an open system,
is the docs that like to
prescribe meds and just
naturally practice this
way, collect patients
who like to have medications.
There's a whole lot of
people who believe in meds.
But I'm not one of them, either
as a doctor or as a patient.
And I would tend to collect
patients who think like me.
So I don't think it's
just one or the other.
I think for the people who
are reluctant to take meds,
they don't usually
take meds very much.
And if they can get away
with just taking something
off the shelf, sort of why not?
So I think that's how I
would answer that question.
I'm not sure if I got
to the nubbin of it.
Because you started out by
talking about everything
moving faster and faster.
And that as a patient, how can
you get things to slow down?
And in a way, I don't even
think it's as a patient.
It's as a person.
I mean I think--
so this is, again,
maybe a little off
for me talking about.
I think as far as
our health goes,
we couldn't live
in a society that
was more difficult to
be sane, and centered,
and enjoy your life than the
society you live in right now.
And I think-- you
know, "sane" actually
is from "sanus," which
means "healthy" in Latin.
And "health," which
is "solus," actually
is connected to salvation.
Then I like the one that's
"hello," which actually means
"health to you."
Because in old English,
"hal" was health.
And they're all related
to this idea of wholeness.
So whole, and hal, and
health, and wealth--
I think.
I haven't looked that up yet.
But I decided the other
day, I think wealth fits
into this wholeness model.
We're fragmented.
Our attention is fragmented.
We're just in this kind of
piecemeal, sort of state.
And I think it's not
a good state to be in.
REBECCA MOORE: Another question.
AUDIENCE: Building on Salim's
thing, I think he says--
I think it's separating
symptom from the source.
So if you have a headache,
and that's a symptom, you say,
I can take an Advil.
And that will go away.
And you can just keep
doing that for a while.
But you're not addressing
the root cause.
So if I can treat a symptom,
I will deal with it myself.
But if I can't get
past that, then that's
where I go to the doctor,
to help me figure out
what's actually going on.
VICTORIA SWEET: Correct answer.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Well, you're
supposed to comment on that.
VICTORIA SWEET: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
I totally agree with it.
It's exactly right.
That's exactly it.
Is, if you can make it go away
on your own, and that's-- then,
I don't have a problem
with that actually.
I think that's a good way to go.
AUDIENCE: That's your
measure of efficiency though.
Are you looking at
[INAUDIBLE] efficiencies?
I had a headache today.
I took a pill.
It went away.
It looks like it's
extremely efficient.
But if every single day
I'm taking this pill,
and I'm constantly dealing
with that, over the long term,
that's extremely inefficient.
And if I treat the
source of that,
it takes me longer
to treat the source,
but it solves it for a
much longer duration.
And therefore, it's much more
efficient in the long run.
VICTORIA SWEET: Good answer.
It is.
It's super.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: To get
to Salim's point,
I think it's very hard for a
certain segment of patients
to get over that.
They want the quick fix.
So, in some ways,
many physicians
respond to that by prescribing.
I think many-- and I speak
as a physician myself.
Many of us would like to sit
down, talk to our patients,
spend time.
And sometimes patients,
like me, doc, I
don't have time for this.
I'm not going invest
in my health care.
I just want-- give
me the antidepressant
and I'll feel better.
And I'll have time
for therapy later.
But I don't have time
for that right now.
So there's this
whole sea change,
that has to also start from the
patient point of view, actually
wanting to invest
time in themselves.
AUDIENCE: And if you have
to see a thousand patients,
you don't have time to do that.
VICTORIA SWEET: Correct.
REBECCA MOORE: Anyone else?
So I one last question, maybe.
Do you feel that
you, as a clinician,
that you are alone in this?
Or, as you go around
and you're talking
with other doctors, and nurses,
and so on, around the country,
is this message of slow
medicine resonating?
VICTORIA SWEET: Yeah.
It sure is.
And I sometimes wish I was
a lot more of a general,
rather than a philosopher.
Because there's a whole movement
that is brewing out there.
There's so much frustration
among doctors, and nurses
especially.
I mean as much
nurses, as doctors.
That, we're just stuck
in front of the computer.
It's just maddening.
So there's a huge--
I've spoken to, like,
thousands of people
by now, personally, in
all these different talks.
And everybody wants
something done
about it, which is
one of the things I've
thought about electronic
health records and getting--
because that would at least
get us off the computer.
It's not complicated.
I don't think it's as
complicated a solution as it
looks like at first, if we
can just get back the time.
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
We'll have [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Since
we're at Google, I'd
be curious about your comment
on the use of Google Glass
in the doctor/patient setting.
So a clinic, that
I will not name,
has now gone to
using Google Glasses.
So you walk into the
clinic, the room.
Your doctor has a
Google Glass on.
And on the other side
of the Google Glass
is a transcriptionist, probably
in India somewhere, outsourced,
that is documenting
every single word
that occurs between
you and your physician
during that encounter.
So in some ways, it's
taking more time.
The doctor doesn't have
to do the data entry.
But there's this third
person in the room,
through the Google Glass,
that your wonderful--
an amazing company has enabled
doctors to use this technology.
But it has affected the
doctor/patient interaction.
Many of my colleagues
who are using it,
claim that its given
back their lives.
That they're now completing
all of their charting
within the course of the day.
They're going home.
And they're not taking
their charts home with them
because they don't have
to because everything
is transcribed for them.
But I'm wondering, from
all of you, and from you,
what your perspective on this
as a possible solution would be?
VICTORIA SWEET: That seems
to me not a solution,
but a possible problem.
I mean-- I just--
I was just horrified
when I heard about that.
I mean, I can't imagine
anything worse than going
into my patient like this.
Hi.
I'm Dr. Sweet, trying
to look at the Google
Glass and their records out
of the corner of my eye.
It just seems whacked.
There is something called
the Scribe, which--
it gives me the same
feeling, which is doctors--
so they don't have to sit
in front the computer.
Now, there's an actual, physical
third person, who follows you
in the room and fills out your
electronic health records,
while you supposedly are talking
with the patient, which is,
as an example, a
lot better solution,
I think, than the Google
Glass, where at least you're
physically looking
at the person.
But Rebecca, do you have any
thoughts on Google Glass?
REBECCA MOORE: Well,
actually I have a clinician
who wanted to do that.
And I was uncomfortable.
And she did give me an option,
that you didn't mention,
which is--
what I was uncomfortable
with was Google Glasses,
about looking at things.
It's not just about
audio transcription.
And so it could be
beaming images, right,
which feels like it could be
a violation of the patient's
privacy.
So there were two modes.
So the mode that I
allowed her to use
was just recording audio.
But even so, that
eyewear, I felt
as an imposition in that
trust relationship, personal.
Anyway.
Anything else?
Oh, one-- Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] legal.
You have to have this paper
trail of absolutely everything.
And that's part of what's
inhibiting your efficiency.
VICTORIA SWEET: Could
you say it a little--
AUDIENCE: How much of it
is driven by legal reasons,
and not like big
data and collecting?
VICTORIA SWEET: Oh.
I see what you mean.
AUDIENCE: By having
a paper trail and--
VICTORIA SWEET: Yes.
Yes.
Well, we have we do like to
document things for malpractice
reasons.
But if you just handwrite
it, it's perfectly fine.
It doesn't have to be in
a computer per se, at all.
So there's no
reason that we have
to have a clumsy electronic
health record, that
takes all our time and produces
big data, in order to document.
It's actually much
better documentation
if I actually write
the story about you.
This 32-year-old woman came
in with chronic headaches.
And I thought this.
And we did this.
And this is what I think
it is, kind of the story,
than it is to have what I
found with my father, which
was incomprehensible.
So that's not the legal thing.
There is a legal piece
that the United--
the one reason we've gone
to having electronic health
records was that in
2009, there was hidden
in the Reconstructing
America Act, this little--
what did they call it--
sorry-- this little
sublaw thingy,
that every doctor,
that has anything
to do with the federal
government I think,
has to have their
electronic health records.
That's how it happened.
It didn't happen gradually.
It was like 2009.
And then they would start taking
money out of your practice
if you didn't have
electronic records.
So it was one of the
reasons that suddenly they
took this billing platform
and just immediately tried
to add things on, so they
could sell it to the doctors
and doctors could do that.
So there is some
legal piece of that.
But it isn't so much like
getting sued, kind of thing.
It's more like government.
REBECCA MOORE: I do
want to point out
that Dr. Sweet is one of the
few people on the planet who's
actually read the entire
Affordable Care Act.
VICTORIA SWEET: 922
single-spaced pages.
It's as long as
Harrison's "Principles
of Internal Medicine."
REBECCA MOORE: OK.
On that note, thank
you very much.
VICTORIA SWEET: Thank you
very much for having me.
[APPLAUSE]